one a referendum like brexit where I
voted remain by the way you couldn't
vote for Hillary in 2016. interesting
well and Francis did too as well we both
did
when the explanation for that that was
being offered to us was that half the
country was I was just like no this is
BS this isn't true and that I think is
part of the reason that we really
started to look at these things because
we felt our own industry change and also
we looked around at society and we just
went something is off we're being told a
bunch of lies and and quite nasty ones
as well you know for Francis
particularly
um you know his father is is a is a evil
straight white man uh who married a
woman from Venezuela in the 80s when
that was not the done thing in England
uh and he voted brexit and he was he he
was suddenly demonized and it just that
picture of the our societies is so
inaccurate that it was very frustrating
and I think trigonometry is partly born
out of that frustration
I'm Dave Rubin and we are at the local
Studio here in Miami and joining me
today is the co-host of the trigonometry
podcast and author of an immigrant's
love letter to the West Constantine
kissing Constantine this is bizarre that
we have never met in person before and
it is awesome that we now have we have
what should we do now let's talk but
let's talk about stuff okay
I think some people sort of think you
are like the British version of me in a
way so what's the deal well give me a
little history listen um I'm I'm gonna
spill the beans uh I used to watch your
show religiously particularly
2017 2018. those crazy formative years
yeah and uh I thought what you were
doing was incredible uh and you showed
what was possible for somebody who is
independent minded who wanted to come in
um and you know interview interesting
people from a position of perhaps not
knowing very much and so I said to my
buddy Francis why don't we do something
like this it is genuinely seeing you and
Joe uh you know to have these
conversations was an incredible
influence and so I'm delighted to to be
here with you well I'm glad that you are
was nobody really doing that in the UK
yet the the more independent-minded
stuff obviously there's a gajillion chat
shows and and the UK has a long history
of long-form interviews and that kind of
thing yeah I can't think of the top
there are people there are other people
who have slightly different
conversations but I think that mix of
levity with seriousness and that is
something that it's kind of interesting
because we're both former standards yeah
uh and Francis still does stand up and I
think that gives you something because
you you've always got a way to release
tension if you need to and for us it's
been very important because you know we
interviewed a woman Dr Ella Hill who's a
survivor of one of these grooming gangs
I don't know if you're familiar with
them and we interviewed her for an hour
and this isn't really anything to do
with us but nonetheless it's an
interview about a victim of the most
heinous crimes which is funny is funny
right and and that I think is is the
magic Source was she ready to be funny
about it yeah it's all down to her we
were just able to play along that's all
yeah so you're out of the stand-up game
huh yeah I I I hated the lifestyle I
enjoyed being on stage but driving
around for hours and all of that that's
funny because for me too I I loved love
love doing stand up and you know I do
gigs still here and there in book tours
and that kind of thing it was never the
the being on stage or being at the
comedy clubs it was everything else it
was the life that it could lead to that
that I couldn't deal with which I think
is is why so many Comics end up on drugs
or dead basically it's a it's look there
are harder lives obviously no no no
other people and talking working in rice
fields you know getting home at 2AM uh
waking up at you know 10 the next day
it's just not it's I can't do it and now
you and I both are fathers so I it's
it's not for me when lockdown happened
in the UK it forced me to really really
evaluate it and my wife we've been
married for 20 years we have the most
beautiful relationship but I was working
so hard because we were trying to get
trigonometry off the ground we were
doing stand-up both of us Francis was oh
wow married a comic too well no my I
married a couple no no I'm talking about
Francis I thought you said my wife he
said my wife we did stand it she did
yeah sorry I'm may be misspoke oh I
maybe maybe Francis is my work wife at
this point uh no what was happening was
basically both Francis and I were
working extremely hard yeah and by the
time lockdown came even though my wife
and I have a beautiful relationship it
was kind of like locked down sort of I
wouldn't say it saved our marriage but
our son certainly wouldn't have been
born without it you know what I mean
because suddenly I was like oh oh I'm at
home now and maybe maybe I should
actually spend some time with this
person that I claim to love so either I
misheard you or you referred to him as
your wife in either case one of us is
not looking very good here well it's
probably me yes probably not probably
not so for people that just that that
don't know you don't know your work uh
can you just talk a little bit about
your sort of childhood and into into
what got you into sort of the cultural
political thing that we're kind of in
the mix of and then we'll hit the the
issues of the day well the short version
of us I was born in the Soviet Union in
the late 80s uh into a family that I was
imbued from a very young age with
stories of my ancestors people who
starved in the gulags for saying the
wrong thing or who were really severely
punished my grandfather the way I ended
up in the UK is my parents they were
very wealthy for like three years and in
that time Gap they sent me to boarding
school in England because my grandfather
was there and the reason my grandfather
was there that it was that in the late
70s early 80s he criticized the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan and he was
immediately ostracized by his friends
fired from work his wife was fired from
work his children that's my father and
my aunt were kicked out of University
but him making this one comment in
private and so when it came to living in
the UK and doing stand-up and I saw this
climate that was happening where
suddenly it was very very sudden at
least to me because I wasn't paying that
much attention suddenly words became
this all-powerful thing that would that
was to be treated with the utmost
seriousness and jokes could not be
treated as jokes if you made a joke that
people didn't like they couldn't just
say oh that's not funny now you had to
be punished and in addition to that you
know the one thing that I really as an
immigrant to to the UK I found very
unpleasant was
this idea that all our social problems
whether that's you know brexit or Trump
or whatever can be explained by claiming
that people are racist and that's when I
came across your show actually because
uh I I was trying to understand because
I'd lived in England for all my most of
My Teenage life and all my adult life
and I'm a dark-skinned immigrant I
experienced racism once or twice but it
was never I never felt like it was a
racist country and so when a referendum
like brexit where I voted to remain by
the way you couldn't vote for Hillary in
2016. well and Francis did too as well
we both did
when the explanation for that that was
being offered to us was that half the
country was I was just like no this is
BS this isn't true and that I think is
part of the reason that we really
started to look at these things because
we felt our own industry change and also
we looked around at society and we just
went something is off we're being told a
bunch of lies and and quite nasty ones
as well you know for Francis
particularly
um you know his father is is a is a evil
straight white man uh who married a
woman from Venezuela in the 80s when
that was not the done thing in England
uh and he voted brexit and he was he he
was suddenly demonized and it just that
picture of the our societies is so
inaccurate that uh it was very
frustrating and I think trigonometry is
partly born out of that frustration
right it's interesting because I wasn't
talking about brexit that much at first
but then because of the Trump situation
here I started having a couple people
from the UK and some Americans that were
talking about brexit and then suddenly I
had all these people in the UK watching
and I was like well I didn't even intend
that to happen but there was definitely
a connection between brexit and the
Trump thing for sure there was and and
the cultural forces that swirl around
those issues are largely the same now
you guys do politics very differently to
the way that we do but fundamentally the
way I see it it was a sort of it was a
rebellion of the people uh whether it
was channeled in the right way is a
different conversation uh but people
certainly in the UK felt that a lot of
their concerns were not being not only
heard but they weren't even being aired
and so that I think is why those two
issues are very similar if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell